[Music]
but really check your notes because
after Trump lost like a
dog I'm pretty sure what he said was I'm
so depressed I've stopped
cheating
it's not so
[Applause]
controversial new did you stack this
audience with a bunch of
trumpers
probably right people it is Monday
December 4th 2023 and I did not stack
that audience with trumpers I stacked it
with sanity that's exactly what happened
yes if you did not see it I was finally
about 20 years in the making on Real
Time with billar on Friday that's why we
had no Friday show we got the the call
while I was doing the live show on
Thursday quick flight out there
rearranged a bunch of things it was sort
of ironic because I was n route
literally on the plane going to
California as the big Nome DeSantis
debate was happening so I'm leaving the
free state of Florida to go to
California for one of the few things
that could drag me back to Los Angeles
uh I was able to watch some of the
debate we will be covering a bit of that
today since I wasn't able to do it on uh
on Friday uh but mostly what we're going
to do today is frame the show around my
appearance on real time because I want
to give a couple points of credit to to
Bill and the realtime uh producers
because they said to me what do you want
to talk about you know Bill wants
obviously we'll talk about Cali and
Florida and Dan santis and Nome and
we'll talk about Israel and I was
pushing on some of the free speech and
big Tech stuff and Elon and all that but
the show ended up really being framed
around a lot of the things that we're
covering here and I think I did pretty
much as respectable a job as one could
do uh defending the ideas I talk about
here while still engaging in an in an
honest and and hopefully a bit funny way
at times and uh we're going to unpack a
whole bunch of that if you want to join
us for the postgame show join us at
Ruben report. locals.com and even if you
don't want to join us for the postgame
show uh you know when we did do the live
show on Friday at 11:00 a.m. as usual I
was able to alert the locals people
because they get push notifications when
I post things and all that stuff so if
you just want to stay in touch with us
and that that is all for free that's all
for free it's just Ruben report.
locals.com so yes I am feeling quite
good I think it was a really great
appearance I suppose it's not really for
me to say I know the producers were
happy and Bill immediately said you'll
be back and all that stuff but I I laid
out my case we did everything from very
fine people on both sides Donald Trump
we did the Newsome D santis stuff is
musk and anti-semite and sort of when
does the left go a bit too far so let's
start with this was about halfway
through the show we oh no this was on
the overtime segment right was this
overtime or during the main show itself
it was this was on the main show so the
way they do it you have about 25 minutes
on that panel you know they had the
original in interview was with David
Mammoth that was the one-on-one Bill did
and I've had David mammo on the show
incredible playwright and author uh so
Bill and him did the one-on-one for
about 10 minutes then they throw to the
panel which was me and James Carville
for those of you who who don't remember
James Carville he was huge in the sort
of 90s early 2000s uh major player in
the Bill Clinton machine and the Bill
Clinton presidency and campaign and all
that stuff uh anyway he's a Democrat
strategist uh but you have about 25
minutes on the main show and then we did
about a 20 minute or so bonus show
that's on YouTube and I think they air
that on CNN probably the only time in my
life I'll ever be on CNN anyway on the
main show uh they were obviously talking
about Trump I kept trying to direct
things towards a better alternative
perhaps that Florida disantis
alternative but they kept going to Trump
Trump trump and then very fine people on
both sides came up take a look I'm I'm
getting ready for the next Trump term
already uh he says he under his administ
under his administration his next one
schools will teach students to love
their country not to hate their country
like they're taught now I got to say
this one doesn't bother me so much
because I think that I mean this is what
I see when I see kids demonstrating
these Progressive progressives
demonstrating for Hamas the most
illiberal people in the world that oh
good we're going to give America it's
come up in America this is they
kind of have been indoctrinated this way
vulnerabilities in the party James the
Democrats have a big split
generationally on this issue the kids
seem to be with the
Palestinians and the older generation
seems to be with Israel well the kids
are with Tik Tock they're with whatever
Tik Tock tells them to be for basically
well that is where a lot of what were a
good people on both sides of
Charlottesville I don't know did I hear
that or did I make that up that Trump
said they're good people on both sides
he he didn't say that he did not he he
well he said it but a sentence later he
said I'm not talking about the white
supremacists and and the neonazi
yeah it's likeing on it was badly
phrased think we can agree on that it
was inelegant yeah it was inelegant okay
so I know I didn't say much in that
segment but I think I said the thing
that needs to be said we have heard this
hoax endlessly for years Joe Biden when
he launched his campaign video you may
remember this he said the reason he was
running for president was because of
what Donald Trump said in
Charlottesville now of course I have
debunked this a million times several
other people have debunked it but it
keeps getting repeated even on real time
and of course on CNN and MSNBC and
everywhere else that Donald Trump said
there's very fine people on both sides
uh meaning that they're meaning that
somehow neo-nazis and white supremacists
are good people but of course that isn't
what he said because a sentence after he
had condemned the neo-nazis and the
white supremacist we've got a quote from
Trump himself you had some very bad
people in that group but you also had
people that were very fine people on
both sides uh the reporter says the
neo-nazis started started this they
showed up in Charlottesville to protest
excuse me excuse me they didn't put
themselves and you had some very bad bad
people in that group but you also had
people that were very fine people on
both sides you had people in that group
excuse me excuse me I saw the same
pictures as you did you had that people
in that group who were there to protest
the taking down of to them a very very
important statue and renaming of a park
from Robert elely to another name so you
get the point when when he was talking
about very fine people on both sides I
know you guys know this he was saying on
the debate as to whether we should take
down statues not whether white
supremacists are good people or not uh
anyway one guy who has been hitting this
probably even harder than me for years
now is Scott Adams you guys know Scott
Adams he's a friend creator of Dilbert
legendary
cartoonist and I would say a guy that
end has ended up being a trump supporter
who describes himself mostly as a lefty
but he does not like hoaxes uh Scott
gave me a little credit so we thought it
was worth showing you first Dave
rubben well he didn't say that uh
because a few few seconds later he
clarified that he was not talking about
the neo-nazis and the white supremacist
and now James caral fact checked on the
biggest hoax in American politics
would you like to see it
again maybe the finest day in American
politics how long have I been waiting
for
this how long have I
been trying to get rid of this stupid
hoax now it this won't get rid of the
hoax because the people who are sold on
it will still be sold on it but here's
what we do
know James Carville knows it was a
hoax we do know
that now you tell me do you think
anybody in the audience caught this you
know do do you think that the at least
the Democrats were watching the show do
you think that they caught
that I don't know but maybe a few maybe
a few few people just
became pre-trump the reason I'm showing
you that is not to have Scott Adams say
nice things to me but it is or about me
it's to the it's to illustrate the last
part maybe a few people caught on to it
you have to understand not only did Joe
Biden launched his campaign with this
but for years the mainstream media has
been using that Charlottesville moment
as a moment to try to prove that Donald
Trump was somehow in it with neo-nazis
and white supremacists I went on really
the biggest Lefty liberal show and
debunked it now it doesn't mean that the
whole audience is going to be like holy
cow we better Google that and maybe
Dave's right but they didn't have any
push back James carille he and Bill then
said it was inelegant what Trump said
which wasn't much of a defense
considering this is what they have said
has been the biggest craziest you know
proof of his white supremacy and his
Nazi Hitler loving stuff so that was
that was just one little node that I put
in there there and I think that that's
if I learned anything by this being my
first appearance is you just have to
effectively pick your spots you don't
want to Rampage through and and sort of
talk over everybody and everything else
but you can pick your moments you know
some guys talking here some guys talking
here to lay out some truth and I think I
tried to consistently do that throughout
we'll get into a couple more of those in
just a moment as it relates to Dan
santis and Nome but before we do let me
talk to you about moink box you guys
know that 60% of us pork production
comes from one company by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
guys there's a better way I want to tell
you about moink that's moo plus oink
moink delivers grass-fed and grassfish
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild Cod Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the moink difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping Family Farm stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like ribe eyes to chicken breast to pork
chops to Salmon Fila and much more plus
you can cancel anytime Shark Tank host
Kevin o called moinks bacon the best
bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you you'll say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got moinked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moink box.com Ruben rightow and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time m inkbox.com
moo.com rubben and now back to me all
right so the other thing that really
took up I would say the first 10 minutes
of my appearance was Florida vers
California and of course Ronda santis
versus Gavin Nome now what was
interesting about it was every time I
tried to bring up a point about Florida
a good point about Florida or a good
point about Ronda santis immediately
everything kept getting turned back to
Trump here is exhibit a
we have kind of a clear idea of what
Trump's second term if he gets elected
is going to look like shoot shoplifters
on
site and I assume if he's I'm from
Florida don't look at me you know well
no I'm looking at you because I assume
if he's the nominee you will vote for
this you're going to vote for the
Republican I want Ronda Sanz to be
president I know but it's going to be
Trump we don't know well 41 so he's
going to make up 41 points 41 points I
mean I look at these polls like the
polls are from 700 people via text who's
of two weeks who's lying
now you you think you think de santis is
going to is going to beat Trump for the
nomination or N I told you who I want to
and I don't know what's going to happen
but nobody knows what's going to happen
I think if he wins Iowa than anything
possible so so Michael George santz is
having a better year than Ronda santz
okay santis is throwing spaghetti
against a goddamn wall he's coming on
Bill Moore he's trying to
hey wait a second am I the wall here no
but but if a a right-wing Republican
that comes on here he's desperate you
pointed it out when I saw a clip of him
on the show the fact that if you were
ahead you wouldn't be here okay I mean
did exactly no no no he did exactly what
we all want candidates to do which is
talk to the other side so I was here
that day with you and and I I think it
was for him to be here and lay out his
case is actually what we all want isn't
it what you were just asking taking
advantage of desperate politicians is my
business
many okay first off credit where credits
due that's a great line by Bill that's
funny okay but I think what you can see
there is again I consistently just tried
to calmly lay out a position nobody
knows what's going to happen you can
tell me whatever the polls say in 40
points 50 points etc etc but nobody
knows and I also said you got to look at
the polls and these polls are off by 700
people it's via text and everything else
the real reason I bring it up though is
it's fairly obvious to me that the
Liberals the lefties and I say this now
as as someone that I consider myself
friends with Bill they really want Trump
to be the nominee right because they
think Trump is far more beatable also I
was glad that it came up uh about
DeSantis going on his show because yes
what do we all want I thought we all
wanted people to sit down with people
from across the aisle and do all that
moments before that bill was giving
Gavin Nome credit for being with Hannity
so it's like you can't then attack the
santis for that but I want to illustrate
something about the points sorry about
the polls because Bill's point was oh
you're you're not believing the polls so
I saw a poll from traler yesterday I
want to read a tweet that I put out this
morning and I want to dive into these
polls a little bit more and you guys
tell me what you think so here's what I
tweeted Monday morning thought as I
mentioned to Bill Mah on real time on
Friday these polls showing Trump is up
by 50 points are all ridiculous ly
flawed check this by traler which is
supposedly reputable
1,84 people responded over 4 days but
the response rate was only
1.4% so basically 99 out of every
hundred people they called ignored them
that's about a hundred people who just
hung up does that seem like a legit
sample to you when virtually everyone
they reach out to ignores them have you
ever been called by a polling agency
after 3 years of Co do you actually
trust experts in polls has there ever
been a time in American politics when we
have been told we shouldn't have debates
and candidates should drop out before
the primaries so now the question is why
does mainstream media keep pushing them
pushing them so the poll that they
showed now you can see in the black in
the middle uh they have Trump at 54%
basically DeSantis at about 17 Nikki at
about 16 etc etc the screenshot
Nationwide survey I went into the poll I
actually clicked it right I actually
clicked it and and uh as you can see the
response rate was
1.44% so you really need to understand
this they got a thousand people to
respond but with a response rate of
1.44% means 100,000 people ignored them
100,000 people so when you see that
these polls all have Trump up
tremendously well first off a huge swwa
of people 99% of the people basically
ignored the poll and then I do accept
that the the Trump
obviously is the most rapid nobody's
denying that the question is what
percentage of the party is that most
people seem to think it's about 30% that
means about 70% of the party is somewhat
malleable anyway I am not a polling
expert I'm only bringing this up to show
you that what I said on real time was
true I have never in my life and I don't
think you have either see in a time when
we are being told that certain
candidates shouldn't debate and we
should be canceling primary because ofs
and then all you have to do don't trust
me on this every time they show you a
poll every time you see a poll on
Twitter or Facebook or anywhere else
just look at the methodology of the poll
and if you think that 999,000 people
ignoring a poll and then 1,000 people
are responding and then it happens to
choke out the results you want if you
think that that's legit like it's just
not but I would also say putting
everything else aside shouldn't we all
just be a bit more skeptical of the
narratives that are being forced on us
espe when it comes to events that
haven't taken place yet right we should
all be skeptical of say covid things and
all of the nonsense that were
immigration all the stuff that's
happening right in front of our faces
but these elections haven't even
happened yet so why would you concede
everything to polls think you get my
point anyway we then continued on the
DeSantis Nome debate and uh Bill thought
that Gavin won and obviously James
Carbell he's a Democrat you know
consultant so of course he said that
Gavin won and clearly I was not going to
sit there for that slicks good yeah GL
slick you know what they said something
about Bill Clinton the guy you got
elected slick and he won two you know
let me tell you something the United
States have babies you have to be a
little slick because they can't take the
truth now what was your
take I know you love well I suppose that
he is slick and that he is a lizard
person but but everything every single
what does that mean well lizards are are
slippery but every single thing that he
said was a lie everything he said I mean
this place California and come on bill
this place did you see the homeless
encampment right outside this studio
right outside the studio I actually
brought some fenel I talk about I got I
talk about California's problems a lot
which is probably why go Governor Nome
has not been on the show in six years
yeah so I don't pull my punches on that
I understand that oh no I'm not saying
you pull your punches but but the fact
is every number that Hannity pulled out
there whether it's homelessness whether
it's the amount of people that left
California to move to Florida whether
it's what's going on with all the woke
stuff that I know you do care about and
all the rest of it Florida is
flourishing this place is falling apart
so I think I made my case I think I did
it effectively I've still got some of
that fenel left if any of you guys want
it let me know but there quite literally
was a homeless encampment on the street
on Beverly Boulevard where the uh what
is it the CBS Studios where they shoot
this thing are from and Bill knows now
what was also interesting about that was
that bill was like I've been very
critical so he hasn't been on my show in
six years well you're also Bill very
critical of DeSantis and DeSantis showed
up and chatted with you so what is it
about Gavin Nome that will not allow him
to show up and talk to a guy who's been
critical of him who he also says he's
supporting he's saying that he will vote
for Gavin Newsome if he is the nominee
so now I want to connect this to what
happened on Thursday the day before
which of course was the big Gavin Ronda
santis debate I know you guys have
probably seen some of these clips but I
want to plow through a couple of them
because I think they perfectly
illustrate what is happening in this
country we can either be a country of
Law and Order and of relative sanity and
of you know I don't know how about
equality over equity and not being
racist rather than being Neo rist and
everything else or we can go down the
path that the left has been trying to
take us so let's start uh here is Gavin
Nome while debating Ronda santis uh
refusing to say what's in these books uh
we all know it's uh what's in these
books that we are Banning here in
Florida for children you can still get
the books if you're an adult uh and it's
yeah porn it's porn Okay go some of the
books you're talking about one is called
the governor just brought it up it's
called gender queer a memoir explicit
pornographic book showing sex acts
another flamer graphic book about young
boys performing sex acts at summer camp
uh this book is gay a book containing
instructions on the ins and outs of gay
sexuality let me finish uh let's talk
about it a book that contains graphic
descriptions about how to masturbate for
males and females my question to you
Governor Nome those books do you believe
that's appropriate for school districts
to teach kids yes or no come on those
aren't not it's not part of the
curriculum they're not
teaching those are books that were in
school hold on hold on the bottom line
is you are in a book Banning binge your
state
1,46 books
3,362 in this country you didn't answer
about those books that's not we don't
provide for K through third grade
education that kind of curriculum it's
just made up these guys make it up it's
part of this cultural Purge it's just a
made find but what I find offensive Sean
and Ron what I find offensive is the a
very significant number of these books
happen to be lgbtq books that a
significant number of these
books African
amans honly you think it'si we don't
teach that we have sex education in
middle schools and high schools where
it's appropriate this is a gend up
madeup issue to divide this country he's
just extraordinary like I I truly don't
think I've ever hated anyone on Earth as
much as I hate this man who most likely
is going to be president which could be
problematic for all of us we're going to
have to look into that um but everything
he said there was a lie he's playing
this little sort of semantical game
about whether it's in the curriculum or
not first off we know it's in schools it
doesn't mean it's in every second grade
class but he's like well it's not in K
through three well do you think that
kids learning about all of the stuff I
don't even need to repeat it right I
don't even need to repeat it hearing
Sean Hannity say the word masturbation
is not very pleasant no one on Fox was
happy hearing that everyone knows this
stuff is not uh is not appropriate for
kids and at the very least you should
know what your kids kids are learning
right and and of course of course
everyone also knows that there are some
books that are appropriate for some kids
at some age but that should be in
conjunction with the parents and the
teachers in the administration deciding
what's what not just the teachers being
able to secretly teach certain things or
talk to kids about sex and gender you
guys know all this already so everything
he says there is an absolute Lie by the
way when he then says this thing about a
thousand books have been ban no there's
been a about a thousand books that indiv
idual school districts have have uh
started discussions on whether they are
appropriate for what library so for
example would you want mine comp in the
elementary school library would that
make sense obviously not would it make
sense to have in a high school library
that's Up For Debate so these are the
things that individual school districts
so what Florida has done is actually
given the power back to the parents and
the teachers as opposed to top down but
you get it he just lied about absolutely
everything uh here's Dan santis pushing
back on Nim and his nonsense the role of
the schools to educate kids not
indoctrinate kids it's not to impose an
agenda it's to do the basics and what
we've said in Florida is it's
inappropriate to tell a kindergartener
uh that their gender is a choice it's
inappropriate to tell a second grader
that they may have been born in the
wrong body now California has that uh
they want to have that injected into the
elementary school my wife and I have a
75 and a three-year-old we don't think
that that's appropriate I know most
parents do not think it's appropriate uh
it's also important to respect parental
rights to know what curriculum is being
used in the classroom and everything
should be age appropriate I actually
have something that I brought that some
parents have objected to so this is a
book that's in some of the schools in
California Florida this is not
consistent with our standards called
gender queer I it's some of it's blacked
out you would not probably be able to
put this on air this is pornography it's
cartoons it's aimed at children uh and
it's wrong so this should not be in
schools uh when people like on the left
say that somehow you're Banning books by
removing this from a young kid's
classroom no this is not age appropriate
and so we're going to stand for the
rights of parents I think we need to do
that Nationwide I don't think you can
have a situation where some states just
trample on the rights of parents parents
have a fundamental right to direct the
education and up I mean that's just D
santis at his best like calmly cooly
just telling the truth you know it's
it's it's so hilarious how the left has
drag us into the abyss you have to have
a presidential candidate standing up
there with a cartoon of basically kids
having sex that's what it was that he
has to black out because they can't show
it on Fox right remember when he did a
press conference a couple months ago and
he tried to show it and literally the
the local Florida news had to cut away
because they felt it wasn't appropriate
to show on television Fox could not show
it and yet Nome over there thinks that
kids should be seeing those books like
we all know what the truth is so that's
just him that's the santis I would say
doing Peak Des santis just calmly
cleaning he's cleanly he's not angry
it's just like here's reality you guys
want to join me in reality or not here
he is just absolutely murdering new let
me just say something about parents race
because he says California respects
parents' rights this is Rich he's been
telling a lot of Whoppers tonight this
may be the biggest in California if
you're a parent in Iowa or New Hampshire
South Carolina your minor child can go
to California
without your knowledge or without your
consent and get hormone therapy puberty
blockers and a sex change operation all
without you knowing or consenting how in
the heck is that you honoring parents'
rights when you're bringing people from
out of state to go around their parents'
backs and getting life-altering
surgeries that is radical that is
Extreme that is an assault on parents
rights you know what it's not for you to
decide it's for the parents to decide
parents do not want kid going to these
other man he is so evil it's like my jaw
is dropping as I'm watching it even
though I've seen it 10 times Nome these
kids just want to survive think how
psychotic that is so an 8-year-old in
Florida says that he is a girl that
means that by California law he is
allowed to go to California against his
parents' wishes and get all of these
drugs and new some and chop up their GS
and everything else and Nome thinks he's
the good guy because they just want to
survive he wants to own your children
like it is as simple as that he wants to
basically show your kids porn and chop
their genitals off generally that would
be thought of as someone that's a bit
weird not when it comes to California uh
anyway here is nuum getting very he's
very offended because he's just offended
because he's so mean to
santis let me stay on a followup let's
turn to the issue of education decy and
humanity and gra it taking ripping
somebody gentle
nobody where's your decency I'm trying
to get as many children here to chop
their genitals off where is your decency
sir and then it got even worse it wasn't
just that the santis didn't want
children's genitals chopped off and he
didn't want children to see pornography
he also mispronounced the vice
president's name which I do on this show
every day and I'm going to continue to
do Joe Biden is in the pocket of the
teachers union and so is Cala Harris
that's why they fought school open when
he came in there
they came into office he brought teacher
be able to do all these different things
to try to keep the schools
closed I just asked uh Connor if he
could bleep me in real time he is unable
to today um could one of you scream at
no just
like you got it if you're if you're
watch if you're listening on the audio
podcast I'm saying the f- word I'm just
mouthing the f- word like where is your
decency Miss pronouncing her name like
she's the queen of England you're just
awful anyway just one more because then
the santis mauled him because of course
Gavin Nome was the mayor of San
Francisco and San Francisco has turned
into a literal hole to the point
that they have a map there is an app
with a map that tells you what street
you should avoid because there's human
and basically the map is all of San
Francisco
enjoy this is a map of San Francisco
there's a lot of plots on that you may
be asking what is that plotting well
this is an app where they plot the human
feces that are found on the Streets of
San Francisco and you see how almost the
whole thing is covered because that is
what has happened in one of the previous
greatest cities this country's ever had
human feces is now a fact of life except
when a communist dictator comes to town
then they cleaned up the streets they
lined the streets with Chinese flags
they didn't put American flags there
they cleaned everything up so they're
willing to do it for a communist
dictator but they're not willing to do
it for their own beautiful just
beautiful and look the the Poop Map and
the poop app is real and I assure you
having walked on the Streets of San
Francisco it's there's poop there's
blood there's there's needles there's
everything you can think of you guys
know exactly what the santis is talking
about when XI jingping went to San
Francisco what was it two three weeks
ago they cleaned up the city and guess
what it's all coming back there are a
ton of videos we should have grabbed one
for you there are a ton of videos coming
out of San Francisco this week now since
they've removed the barriers and
everything I don't know where they
temporarily put those homeless people
but they are back the drugs are back the
entire thing so look the point is guys
that although disantis by any objective
standards I'm sorry I I look I'm
opinionated you're opinionated we all
have our own blinders and anything else
but by any objective standard of what
would have been considered sane 20 years
ago the San is obviously mop the floor
with this lizard person but Nome is a
massive warning signal to America he
represents something about what's to
come if we do not stop the radical
leftists the corporatists the the One
World Government people the just because
he stands there in a suit that fits well
and smiles and because he's slick and we
all know that doesn't mean he's decent
or right it just means that he's slick
it means he's probably really shallow
and it means he's probably really
fascist yeah there I said it because
fascism of course is the connection
between it's the it's the Unholy
alliance between corporations and
government and that is something that a
guy like Gavin Nome absolutely loves so
now I want to connect this uh to more
broadly what's happening across the
world right now uh Tucker Carlson went
on the all-in podcast you know the
all-in podcast my friend David saaks is
one of the co-hosts over there uh and uh
Tucker talked about how Nome repres
present the exact type of fascism that
we better be watching out for I also
think that once you decide that like hey
let's just go crazy and you couple that
with true social
disorder like you get to a place where
you can't buy anything at CVS because
it's chained up because shoplifting has
been legalized as it has been in
California what you're going to get is
fascism because people can't live in in
that in they live with chaos like that's
the one thing they can't deal with and
I've covered a couple of wars and that
was my main conclusion the main problem
with war is not that people get killed
it's that people have to live with total
uncertainty and craziness and that's
incompatible with what people want like
that's the that's the worst thing you
know we're all going to die dying is not
the worst thing the worst thing is
living in chaos and we're starting to
live in chaos and so the return to order
is what scares me I think it'd be very
easy and I do think Gavin Newsome is a
fascist I think he's the kind of person
who would have no problem no hesitation
about using the doj to to imprison his
political opponents now Biden is
imprisoning his political opponents but
at least they're lying about it Gavin
Newsome is the kind of person who be
like well yeah you're you're a threat to
the general order and you're going to
jail and I think because we're in a
moment of chaos right now people kind of
want that actually I think one of the
purposes of degrading and confusing our
society is to make way for
authoritarianism even more than we have
now um so that kind of freaks me out
yeah all right Tucker's making a really
deep point there when you see the chaos
on our streets and we're going to get to
some of that in just a moment when you
see what's happening in New York City
and San Francisco and Portland and that
they can jump the turn Styles as you
know and they can steal all the stuff
from the drugstores and you can steal a
PlayStation 5 and four games as long as
it's under $900 from Best Buy and all of
those things the chaos the utter chaos
when they just take over the streets and
you can't go over that bridge cuz we're
protesting for a terrorist group across
the world and all of those things the
chaos only lasts for so long because
people cannot functionally deal with
that over time and eventually you can
feel it can't you feel it that they
would be glad to usher in an
authoritarian society and I really
believe that that's what Gavin Nome was
testing out when he brought XI jingping
in and he suddenly said see I can clean
up the streets I can do it because the
Communist dictator is here and look what
I could do and the homeless people
magically disappeared and he had his
fences up and it was clean and they
power washed the off the streets
and everything else and then of course
Xing ping leaves all hell breaks loose
again that's what's happening on the
streets again because eventually over
time Tucker's right people don't ask
that much we don't ask that much we're
so distracted with our phones and video
games and whatever the nonsense of the
day is all of modernity has left us kind
of
inept right like we don't ask for much
we're just kind of blobs out there and
we'll just take whatever they give us
but at some point when your city is
endlessly burning and you can't go into
stores anymore and all of those things
then you might demand a real
authoritarian leader to clean it up so
now I want to connect this to something
else that happened on real time because
one of the things we started talking
about uh later in the show was how there
are a bunch of uh staffers at the White
House who are not happy with Joe Biden's
policy as it pertains to Israel and Gaza
and they're protesting uh and well take
a look a couple of weeks ago me MERS of
the White House staff protested against
their own president uh we are
Congressional staffers on Capitol Hill
also also these people did and we are no
longer comfortable staying silent well
your staffers you're supposed to stay
silent what are you talking about yeah
you my boss is doing a job and I
thought I'd go public with it I mean
this is hundreds of people in Biden's
staff and on uh congre Democrat
Congressional Democrat staff who are
publicly going against them because
they're not supporting Hamas enough you
fire them period you fire all of them
that's it it's not it's not up for
debate if you had if you had five
staffers standing outside saying Bill
Mah's the devil what are you going to do
you're going to fire them right of
course you're going to fire them it's as
simple as that you fire these people but
the inmates are running the
Asylum yes you fire these if I could
agree with that guy we got to play more
clips of that guy he's good yes you fire
them it it but you see how this is
connected to what I was just talking
about and what Tucker was talking about
in a city where nothing works we don't
have rules anymore right you jump the
Turnell you break the laws we'll
selectively decide who we're going to
prosecute and everything else and then
at the federal government level these
these staffers they're there they're
hired to do the job of the
administration you vote for the
president you vote for Congress and the
and the Senate right your
representatives and the Senators if the
staffers don't like what they're doing
you fire them that's it but but we are
watching the collapse of all of our
systems and the real question is not
what happens during the collapse we're
in the midst of the collapse right now
the question is what happens after the
collapse and as Tucker is pointing out
that's when the fascists show up that's
when Gavin Nome shows up and he uses the
power of the corporations with the power
of the government to to put in the most
authoritarian say 15minute cities
whatever it might be say a social credit
system because people will beg for the
control at that point they will be like
oh my God everywhere I go uh there a
chance of being raped or murdered I
guess I will take all of that
authoritarian control and how do we know
that this is happening well look what's
going on out on our streets I think we
showed you a little bit of this from
last week but here are pro Hamas riots
in New York City right by Fox News and
Rockefeller Center going after Christmas
you'd think that okay fine go for the
Jews but could you ease up on Christmas
well no not for these
[Music]
[Applause]
people
okay so that was in New York City but of
course we know this is not just in New
York City where there are no rules
anymore you want to shut down a street
you want to walk into P private property
and disrupt them you want to break some
windows whatever the hell you want to do
it's New York City go for it we they
basically don't have a police department
anymore you have people that have you
know they have outfits they're wearing
police uniforms but they don't really do
anything and of course that's not just
in New York City here is uh the Hamas
people going after Christmas in
[Music]
Chicago now again I believe in peaceful
protest it is it is one of the tools
that you have as a free person in a free
Society but when we when we sort of get
to the Tipping Point where everything
that brings us together say The Rock
aella Center Christmas
tree a Christmas tree like even even
though Christmas is a religious thing
like there are things that culturally
bring us together the spirit of the
Season all of those things like if at if
we have decided you can close roads for
whatever reason you want you can protest
at Fox News and go enter the lobby in
Fox News which actually that is illegal
but nobody was arrested for that either
you can climb up on monuments you can
vandalize things you can pour uh blood
you know paint That's affected Blood on
the on the steps of the White House you
can do all of these things and you can
just keep getting away with everything
then we have no law and then what will
happen order people will demand order
right that is what they want by the way
speaking of Chicago because they did uh
they did protest the Christmas tree in
Chicago uh this was a very good weekend
for Chicago I guess the Hamas people did
keep people distracted only 13 people
were shot in Chicago this past weekend
only one dead so congratul he was a
13-year-old boy um but congratulations
to Chicago uh because only 13 people
were shot who who said the Hamas guys
are doing all bad work they're keeping
everybody so distracted they're not
shooting their neighbors Hot Diggity Dog
okay but now as we have these people
rampaging through our cities and
nobody's doing anything do you think
there might be a plan do you think that
some bad people Elsewhere on Earth are
watching these young people who have no
idea what they're screaming about
calling for The River To The Sea and
they have no idea of history or anything
else and they're going after Christmas
and it doesn't seem like anyone in the
west is standing up against it we're
just allowing it to happen and by the
way if you went to say Paris or if you
went to London or Brussels or Amsterdam
and you said to them hey do you think we
should do anything about this like how'd
it work out here for you guys 5 10 years
ago when you didn't do anything when
they started chanting and everything
they would all go oh you guys
better do something about it now cuz
it's much much worse now well here is a
a Palestinian uh leader this is in
Jerusalem now remember Jerusalem's
controlled by those pesky Jews over in
Israel but they still allow the Muslims
to pray and do all that stuff and at the
aloa mosque which was built on top of
the ancient Jewish temple that's where
Jesus used to pray okay these are facts
so who do you think was there first if
they built it on top of the ruins of the
temple you can figure it out you don't
need an abacus or anything else uh here
is just this past weekend uh a
Palestinian Muslim leader threatening to
conquer Europe especially he's not happy
with Paris especially France you're
going down
[Music]
[Applause]
buddy
[Music]
you got a problem macron right because
there are now millions of these people
in your country and do they do you think
they care about the history of France do
they do you think they care care about
the current day of France in any way
where French people will live free and
by the way French people are allowed to
be secular if they want they're allowed
to be atheists they are telling you they
are telling us all what they want and we
have the beginnings of it here in
America and the problem is that every
time you talk about this what happens
they call you a racist and we have to be
able to discuss this a little more
cleanly so I did try to do that on real
time as well well when we started
discussing immigration and the problem
that is now happening across the world
it's not about skin color but it is
about culture so what happens is all of
these people whether they're in France
or Belgium or any of the countries that
you just mentioned they're realizing wow
we've got literally millions of people
in our borders that are chanting for
genocide and gas the Jews and the rest
of it and by the way it doesn't stop
with the Jews right I mean they were at
the Christmas tree in Time Square
yesterday or two days ago so people are
realizing that and they're looking for
anybody and for some reason they always
come with crazy hair that will that will
fix some of this stuff so I I kind of
have trouble I think your question was
election in in the Netherlands is that
somebody do you want a short truthful
answer a long yes it does okay it does
because people but understand this
people like immigrants okay what they
don't like is disorder and when you
become the disorder party whatever it is
you pay a price now one of the reasons
that we have in this problem this is
what 3.6% unemployment does for you you
think we're the only people that know
that or you think and by way somebody if
you got a woman that lives in Honduras
and she walks with a 10-year-old and a
six-year-old to the Mexican border and
wants to come in this country come on in
lady you're motivated person we need you
period you can't come we have a border
we have a border we have a country you
either have a country or you don't every
border had refugees every border has
Asylum yeah but you can't just let them
walk in that's what the issue is okay
now what I sh I think I again I think I
held myself with class and dignity and
told the truth you either have a border
or you don't you can't let everybody in
and what Carbell did there and look I I
spent some time with him in the Green
Room beforehand you know one of the
thing I did learn one thing actually by
doing the show uh LA on Friday which is
that I went into his green room right
before we did the show and I just wanted
to say hi to him we've never met before
right so I just so we chatted for about
10 minutes and he's a perfectly lovely
guy off camera so there were moments
there were a few moments where I could
have hit back a little bit harder and I
kind of held my punches a little bit and
I realize the next time I go on this
show or one of these other shows that
you shouldn't say hi to the guests
beforehand because because then you you
do or at least my nature my inherent
nature would be to go a little bit
softer but he did what the standard
Democrat Lefty line on this is right so
he seemingly cannot make a distinction
between illegal and legal imig
immigration he's also talking about this
woman with kids from Honduras who's
traveling 600 miles to get to the United
States and he's going to give her a job
well I should have turned to him and say
well well James what are you hiring for
because I can probably find you an
American who would do that job so but he
says it and people applaud like oh I'd
give her a job and everyone just like
applauds like seals like oh James
carville's so nice he'll give a Honduran
woman who walked 600 miles with kids a
job but he's not hiring what's he hiring
for he's a Democrat strategist these
people don't produce anything I I'm
hiring right now we just hired a new
guys's moving to Florida next week but
like but this is what they do it's like
oh you're such a good guy you just it's
and oh we have unemployment here so
everyone should be able to come anyway I
think you see that I made my point but
the segue to all of the segue that I
want to get you to right now is that
when you are a good guy they will
usually call you a bad guy because if
you say I'm for borders they will say
you are racist now what of course does
that bring us to that was the big story
last week well it was that everyone was
calling Elon Musk an anti-semite we have
literally hundreds of thousands of
people across the world chanting for
genocide of the Jews there's some
confusion as to whether those people are
anti-semites but Elon Musk who has
opened up Twitter allowed us to uh share
the horrific videos of of October 7th
freely who's gone to Israel who's
wearing dog tags from the survivors like
all of the stuff uh I was asked on Real
Time whether Elon is an anti-elite for
day what did you think of Elon musk's
trip to Israel do you think he no longer
Harbors anti-semitic and conspiratorial
beliefs oh well he never had
anti-semitic or conspiratorial beliefs
in the first place but Elon Musk is not
an anti-semite there are plenty of
anti-semites out there you called a
whole bunch of them out during the show
I mean Ela mus going to Israel was
absolutely great I think too many people
now don't believe anything they see but
they do believe Elon Musk so him going
there and saying I saw the 47 minutes of
footage he's wearing dog tags of you
know from one of the families lost their
kids I mean it could there's a lot of
anti-semites out there but Elon Musk is
not one of them maybe true that may be
true I think Bill knows and Bill
interviewed Elon we played some clips of
it what two months ago like he knows
he's not an anti-semite from one I would
say slightly inelegant shall we say uh
tweet that Elon sent Elon obviously is
not an anti-semite right now I actually
I tweeted out that video and Elon did
see it and uh true he wrote true he is
not an anti-semite I'll take his word
for it uh but why is it that Elon Musk
is getting attacked about everything I
want to jump back to a clip we showed
you last week because I think this was
quite right he's getting attacked
because he's trying to do good and when
you try to do good A system that is
largely bad will always go or the good
guys take a look Tesla has done more to
help the environment than uh all other
companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done more for the environment than
everyone any single human on earth how
do you feel about
that I feel about that yeah no I'm I'm
asking you personally how you feel about
that because this goes we're talking
about power and influence and I'm saying
I'm saying what what I care about is the
the reality of goodness not the per
ception of it and what I see all over
the place is people who care about
looking good while doing
evil
them
okay it's just great because you can see
it you can see as I said last week this
thoughtful interesting guy who's done an
awful lot of good and he's made some
money along the way and as I said last
week even if Teslas weren't good for the
environment they're freaking awesome
cars and that's cool too but what he has
had it with is the people who pretend to
be good The Virtue signalers who are out
there waving Hamas Flags calling for
genocide while pretending they are the
good guys the people who will gladly try
to destroy Twitter for defending Free
Speech while they put their boot on the
head of everyone who dare says anything
against them and the beauty the beauty
of what's happening right now and maybe
we will not win this this existential
battle but but the beauty of it is that
courage begets courage right if you tell
the truth it's a Jordan Peterson esque
idea if you tell the truth and stand up
for that what's right maybe somebody
else will and Elon has done that and I
have no doubt that you're trying to do
it in your own life and I'm trying to do
it but now it's even breaking through to
mainstream media so Greg Gutfeld who's
obviously a buddy of mine I think I'm
going to be on the show in New York in
January we're trying to figure it out
but
Gutfeld uh listen to this now Gutfeld is
a truth tell in the first place but
watch how he got a little extra Brave
here at the end of this segment from a
couple days ago it's like extorting
Jerry Nadler with
[Laughter]
salad or blackmailing sports fans by
threatening to cancel
PBS the fact is musk may be the last man
standing between real freedom of speech
and the suffocating block of the
censorship industrial complex which is
made up of government media and Tech
forces he realizes that advertisers have
no no spine and could be easily cowed by
special interest groups in cahoots with
political allies if you don't believe me
I got two words for you Tucker
Carlson w
wow look at
that you think courage begets courage I
mean think about that right you heard
what Tu what Greg says there he then
says Tucker crosson basically saying hey
my network the channel That this thing's
on right now took out that guy he knows
what he's about to say is going to kind
of get him into crap the audience starts
laughing then reverses the laugh that's
not what usually happens at these shows
and the panelists are all like whoa hey
whoa what show are we
on you get the point guys you get the
point and by the way if big Pharma
bailes on Fox if big Pharma bailes on
MSNBC and everywhere else they don't
know where they're going to get their
advertisers so I give my friend Greg
Gutfeld an awful lot of credit I give
you credit cuz I have no doubt that
you're being brave in your own life
however you can and you just got to keep
pushing it one guy who is being uh Brave
in his life is new Argentinian prime
minister Javier Malay and he is the uh
the focus of me Monday today here's the
one that I put up over there
congratulations Javier Malay on becoming
the next president of Argentina and I
think you can see what we did right
there guys if you want to join us uh for
the postgame show in just moments Ruben
report. locals.com people of the
internet where we take your calls will
be live in about an hour uh we have two
many interviews that we put up the week
was just so freaking busy we had to do a
couple mini interviews my interview with
Brian kilm from Fox and Friends he has a
new book out about Booker T Washington
uh that's up right now and my full
interview with Andrew claven who also
has a new book out uh they're both up
across platforms just quick reminder uh
that we do have a new Twitter SLX
account for clips for the show
specifically it's at Ruben report show
so give a follow if you are are on that
platform and I leave you with one more
clip of me on real time I am pretty sure
I got Bill Maher and Emmy for this one
see you most of these people are not far
right by any way that we would think of
far right in that they like that they're
racist I I actually met with Orban in
Budapest and I talked to him for a
little while and all he kept saying was
you know I love hungry that's all I love
my people I love my country that's it I
don't know what accident that was but
that that basically that's a dead on
impression um can you can you do is
[Music]
walk